it's amazing to me how we put ourselves
in compromising situations in the name
of equality I'll explain what I mean by
this so like right we'll have the WNBA
right for equality but it's negative
doesn't make any money no one really
watches it no one really supports it
like that but we have it because
equality in feelings I mean my thing too
I don't think women should be in combat
positions in the military like why
should we weaken our army by putting
people or our military by putting women
in that don't necessarily have the same
physical capability as men because
you're only as strong as your weakest
component so I I'm not saying women
can't join the military but I'm saying
in combat positions Etc this is why for
the longest time women couldn't join
infantry because it compromises the
Integrity of the entire unit because
women just aren't don't have the same
physical capability I'd be pissed if I
went ahead and I signed up and I got a
female in my unit and I get hurt and she
can't drag me to safety well somebody
also explained to me they said that like
a lot of it is like because of the way
men are wired like if a woman gets hurt
in combat it it affects their ability to
be uh stay focused yes that that and
then also what if they're taken as a
prisoner of war yeah